son and see a vulnerable combination for
paper'd tourism accounts for more than
20% of a country's GDP the see also
provides a precious resource water
[Music]
tourists looking for a little luxury
into data prior can check in with
federal Santos the hotel manager checks
over each of the 93 rooms before guests
checking to ensure constant water
supplies the hotel owner invested about
180 thousand euros in seawater
desalination units the system can
produce up to 4,500 litres of water per
hour I cannot guarantee massage massage
because I ever e-ever local what we
guarantee is that our guests will have
enough water and water of good quality
this was one of the main reasons by
investing as well as reducing costs in
the long term it can totally pay for
itself with savings of up to 35,000
euros per year of our support of cancer
treaty signals and wash on the island of
Santiago the dry season prevails for
nine months of the year and that's
reflected in the landscape due to global
warming rainy seasons are expected to
get even shorter every morning Maria
goes for the water connection point at
the scale neighborhood it's one of the
few remaining in the country
Maria spends 40 euros a month to supply
her family of four with water
consumption is limited to 600 litres
every three days each drop of water
counts in the monthly budget of families
in the Cape Verde Islands Vince could
cut over 20 cents each to feel this or
that barrel
it cost me around 4 euros to feel both
of them for euros I don't have that
money every day Google da Costa the Cape
Verdean Gavin's desalination stations on
three island supply
hold on half of the country's population
with fresh water modern equipment
purifies sea water through a process
using membrane to remove salt and other
particles but more than 55 percent of
water gets lost due to leaks and
pipelines and reservoirs and that's
according to the company's engineer who
says this is the main challenge to
expand in water supplies our goal is to
ensure continuity of water production
and the stability of supplies and to
combat losses that are prohibitive a
huge effort has been made to ensure
water supplies are constant in several
neighborhoods we've already achieved
that with water supplied 24 hours a day
some residents and small businesses are
benefitting from the improved supply
Edmilson Fernandez walks at this carwash
which consumes around 30 cubic meters of
salt free water and won more than 20
cars a wash here every day and prizes
start at four heroes your Navasky da
loop it's a good deal yes because it's a
business that turns a profit not much
but it turns a profit and here there are
lots of cars too there are not many
businesses washing cars well done
surrounded by an inexhaustible source
for fresh water production the cave
virgins are making great efforts to
provide your people and the tourists
with constant supplies of disel inators
clean water